are you down with TPP uh I'm not down  with TPP no you're supposed to say yeah  you know me like the hip-hop group don't  tell me what to say you put yourself in  the 24-hour news cycle it's between two  ferns and Hillary tell me what that  experience is like I really regret doing  this I don't like to talk about between  two ferns it needs to be a mystery not  everything needs to be talked about no  so no Donald Trump you rocketed  interview Donald Trump I I don't know if  he would get it he has like the mind  about an 11-year old so I don't really  think he would understand what's going  on  iein plus I feel like I would we don't  have much in common out that his breath  stinks once I make great TV that I met  him and I know his breath Steve's